>>Bill Buzbee: Welcome. My name is Bill Buzbee,
and I am here with Ben Cheng. We are with
Google's Android team and are going to talk
to you today about the new JIT compiler that
was announced this morning.
Now -- Oops. Wrong direction here.
So we've got a live Google Wave going on in
this session, so if you have a browser handy,
hop on over to bit.ly/blzjnf.
>>> (Off mic)
>>Bill Buzbee: Okay. So the way this is going
to work today, we are going to break this
talk into two parts. In the beginning, I am
going to talk a bit about JIT compilers in
general. Why, in particular, we chose this
style of JIT compiler for portable Android
devices, what kind of performance you can
expect to see out of the JIT, and then where
we expect to take this JIT in the future.
Then we're going to shift gears a little bit,
and as you know, this is an open source project,
so all the source code for the JIT is going
to be part of the Android open source release.
And with that source code you will be able
to build some specially instrumented and profiling
versions of the JIT to enable to you do some
more interesting things about seeing how the
JIT interacts with your application. And Ben
is going to talk more about that. He will
dig into performance case studies, show you
how to profile with the JIT, and then talk
to you about one of the features that I think
is particularly cool with the JIT, something
a normal user wouldn't use but as developers
you might be interested in, and that's the
self-verification mode that the JIT has itself.
Now, if you are going to write a program for
Android, you are most likely going to write
it in the Java programming language and then
push the source code through the SDK. And
what pops out at the end is an executable
targeted to the Dalvik virtual machine.
Now, as they mentioned this morning in the
keynote, one of the great things about targeting
a virtual machine is that you can just simply
move an implementation of that virtual machine
to different physical devices with different
underlying processors, different hardware
capabilities, but the application should still
run.
I am not going to go into a lot of detail
about what Dalvik is, our particular virtual
machine, but I will point you to a talk that
was done in Google I/O two years ago. Follow
this link, and Dan Bornstein gave a great
talk about Dalvik, why we chose it and what
are the features.
But I do want to bring out a couple of key
features of Dalvik that are important in this
context.
Number one, Dalvik is an extremely compact
representation for an executable. And that
was so important for us with a mobile device
with limited resources.
Second, it accomplished that largely through
an emphasis on sharing code and data.
And then finally, the Dalvik environment has
a security sandbox system where we process
sandbox security system that enables you to
make sure that information doesn't bleed from
one process to another when you don't want
it to. And that becomes important when we
are thinking about JITs.
Now, at the center of every Dalvik virtual
machine implementation is an instruction-at-a-time
interpreter.
Interpreters, the way they work, they will
go out and fetch one Dalvik instruction at
a time. We call them Dalvik byte codes, pull
the instruction apart, see what it is, that's
called the decode phase, and then go ahead
and interpret it or execute it.
And that execution is done by using actually
the host instructions on the host processor.
But what you have in effect there with interpretation
is an extra stage of execution. So you have
to pull up the byte code, figure out what
it is, then use host instructions to carry
it out, and the CPU will pick up the host
instructions and execute them.
And that extra level of evaluation is what
gives interpreters a bit of a bad name for
being slow. I mean, there's some great reasons
why you would want to use an interpreter,
but the down side is that they are often a
bit slower than natively compiled code.
Now, we didn't that I that -- We think that
sometimes this interpretation gets more of
a bad rap than it really should in an Android
system, and there are several reasons for
that.
First of all, our interpreter is really, really
fast. It's a very well done interpreter.
We had one of our partners benchmark our Dalvik
interpreter against a traditional Java interpreter,
and they told us that the Dalvik interpreter
was roughly twice as fast, which we were happy
to hear.
But the other and perhaps more important reason
is that not everything -- when your application
is running on an Android system, it's not
really in interpretation the whole time. The
system itself has already been natively compiled
and optimized. A lot of the libraries, the
really key libraries, graphics and other things
that you need to run fast, are done in native
code already, so it's really just sometimes
a smallish amount of code that's actually
being interpreted when your program runs.
Ben recently did a little bit of a study with
his phone running over the weekend and found
in typical use, less than a third of the total
execution time was actually spent interpreted.
Most of the time was spent running code that
was already natively compiled and optimized.
And the upshot of that is for most applications,
the interpreter performance is just fine.
And in fact, it's really a benefit there,
because an interpreted environment typically
requires less memory -- a smaller memory footprint
than a natively compiled one. And we will
talk a little bit more about that in general,
but just the high-order bit here is that the
Dalvik byte codes are very expressive for
their size. So if you translate a Dalvik byte
code into say underlying ARM instructions,
you get a significant code expansion.
So keeping it Dalvik is actually a good idea.
But this good enough for most applications
doesn't mean it's perfect. For some applications,
you really, really do feel the pain of interpretation.
Applications in which you do a lot of computation.
And that gets painful, because you experience
the slowdown of the interpreter, which is
often on the order of five to ten times.
Now, we have had two strategies in play --
or two strategies planned to deal with this
slowdown that computation intensive programs
would face. The first of those, the result
we came out last year with the release of
the Android NDK or native development kit.
This was a software development kit that makes
it easier to isolate the compute intensive
portions of your program, rewrite those in
a natively compiled language and then call
them from your Android application.
The other part of the solution is what we
have announced today, and that's the just-in-time
compiler.
A just-in-time compiler still has an interpreter
involved. The interpreter will interpret your
program until it identifies what's the most
compute intensive part of it. What's the really
hot chunks of your program. And then it will
pull those out, compile them and optimize
them into native code so the next time you
invoke that section of code, you are not doing
interpretation anymore, you are just doing
direct execution of the native code.
Now, putting a JIT on Android has been something
we have talked about for a long time internally,
but the big question was what kind of a JIT
can we fit into an Android system?
As it turns out, the JIT design space is pretty
large. I mean, with the popularity of Java,
most people now are familiar with JITs. And
generally, a particular style of JIT, but
actually, there's quite a broad design field.
The way we like to think of it is you can
break it down into -- break the JIT design
down into two axes. Along one axis would be
what does it mean for just-in-time. When do
you do the compilation? You could do it when
you first install the application or maybe
you do it the first time a method is called
or when you page in some code off of disk.
The other axes is what is the unit of compilation?
Do you compile the whole program, a whole
shared library, just a physical page of code?
Or maybe you do a method or a string of instructions
or even a single instruction worth of code
at once.
Looking back over the last 20 years or so
with just-in-time compilers and dynamic translation
systems, you could actually pretty much fill
in every square of that matrix about the chunk
of thing were you compiling and when it was
you were doing the compilation.
And it's not really the case that any one
combination is best. Each combination had
a set of characteristics that were good in
some situations, and bad in another. And what
our trick -- the trick for because to find
the combination that worked really well in
a portable memory constrained device.
So our key requirements going into this process,
we needed to find a JIT system that could
deliver performance using a very small amount
of memory.
From all the talks today you will hear about
how important memory is on these small devices,
and I think you know this. So we couldn't
have a JIT that wasted a lot of memory or
took too much.
The next, it had to co-exist with this processor
container security model. And this -- I won't
get into this too much, but a lot of JIT styles
would have information being bled between
processes, and we needed to avoid that.
And finally, the last two ones are something
that we considered really important for this
type of device. We wanted the performance
that were going to be delivered by the just-in-time
compilation to come to the user quickly. We
didn't want somebody to have an application
that they had to run to warm it up for, you
know, a minute, an hour, a day. We wanted
them to get the boost from compilation as
soon as possible.
And finally, we're kind of sensitive about
this is an interactive device, so we are sensitive
to jerky execution and pausing. We wanted
the transition between interpretation and
compiled code to be really smooth.
So I won't go through the whole matrix. But
the question really came down to two general
classes of JIT styles.
The first one, method-based JIT is what you
are most familiar with in the Java world.
This is what you would see on a server style
JIT.
It starts off with interpreting your program
until it finds the methods that are most frequently
executed, the hot methods. Then it pull out
the code a method at a time, in method size
chunked, do the compilation, and then create
a native version of that method in optimized
host code. There are some great strengths
to this model and that's one of the reasons
it's very popular today, but the biggest one
is you have a really nice optimization window.
If you are doing optimizations, you have to
know what's happening in the code you are
optimizing, but as important, or even more
important, you need to know what's not going
to happen, what can't happen so you can make
the best assumptions You need that these pointers
are not going to alias. You need to know that
this subexpression is never going to be used
again so I can drop it.
And doing compilation in method sized chunks
has that advantage.
Secondly, in this kind of environment where
you are interpreting some of the time and
you are running compiled code other times,
you are going to have to transition between
those two domains. And transitioning at method
boundaries is a nice clean place to do it
because the interpreter and the compiled code
need to know where everything lives in order
to make this whole thing work together.
But weaknesses. It definitely has some. And
the primary weakness is that even though you
have identified what the hot methods are,
all these hot methods are most likely going
to contain some cold code, some code that
isn't going to be executed handling the exceptional
cases, the odd cases.
And with method-at-a-time compilation, you
are going to be spending resources, time and
space, to compile an optimized code that's
never really going to be run.
The other down side to a method-based compilation
system is that it takes a lot more memory
to do the compile. And that's, in part, because
you are compiling more instructions at once,
and also the optimizations you would do, the
kind of flow analysis over the whole method
is pretty expensive in terms of the resources
you need to do the compilation.
And finally, doing all this extra work means
it's going to be longer before the benefit
of that compilation comes to you.
So the other style, the trace-based JIT, this
is a style a lot of people hadn't heard much
about, but it actually is really popular.
It is the style of JIT that is typically used
when you are doing code migrations or virtualizations
of one architecture on another. This was very
popular back in the '90s especially.
What it does is very similar to the method-based
JIT, is you start off interpreting, but you
interpret until you find out what the hot
chunks of code are. But in this case, the
chunks are not contained methods. They are
actually just a run of instructions that will
start someplace, you will execute for a while,
maybe you will follow a branch or two, perhaps
you will identify a loop, and it will pull
out just those instructions, straighten them
out into a straight line trace of code, and
then optimize that straight line trace of
code.
It will take these translated chunks and store
them in a translation cache, and chain them
all together so execution will kind of bounce
from one trace to another.
And this type of trace formation, you don't
actually even need to respect method call
boundaries. You can even have a trace that
goes through a method call.
The great strength of this one is that you
are only optimizing the hottest of the hot
code. It really has to be the code that's
running before you bother to put the resources
in to compiling it.
Another benefit that's a little bit more subtle,
but quite useful, is that this type of JIT
system is typically more tightly integrated
with the interpreter. So you are bouncing
between the interpreter and the translated
code a little bit more frequently, but what
it also means is that you are never very far
away from the interpreter.
So in the translated code, you can arrange
it, if you choose, to have it that the translated
code doesn't have to deal with any exceptional
cases.
If it detects that some assumption that's
made has gone wrong or it sees there's a null
pointer here I have to deal with, it doesn't
actually have to deal with it. It can just
roll back the state, return to the interpreter
and let the interpreter handle all the messy
nastiness associated with handling these unusual
cases. And this actually turns out to be pretty
powerful in allowing a trace compiler to be
simpler and focus really on what's going to
return the performance rather than all the
details about handling every possible corner
case. But, of course, still being correct.
Finally, you get a really rapid return on
investment. The performance comes back quickly.
You are compiling small chunks. You don't
have to wait very long before you decide some
chunk is hot and you can stitch it write into
an application and get the boost from that
compilation right away.
Now, as with everything, there are down sides.
The primary down side in a trace-based system
is it relates to that window of optimization.
You don't really have a good view of the world
outside of the trace when you are optimizing
that trace. You can only optimize within it.
You don't really know what's happening once
you leave the trace, so you have to make kind
of worst-case assumptions with optimizations,
and that limits you somewhat.
Also, if there is -- as I mentioned you are
popping back and forth more frequently with
the interpreted mode versus translated so
if there is an extra cost associated with
making that transition, you are going to pay
it more frequently.
And then finally, these fragments of code
pretty much are always continuously changing
and it becomes very difficult to share changing
fragments of code across processes.
It's actually kind of difficult to share them
even within a process among threads, but we
can do that.
But across processes would be tough.
Okay.
So lots of words.
So let me throw a picture up here and get
back to this notion of what is hot.
Now, Ben took a look at one of the key --
the key processes on a running Android system.
And that's the system server process.
It's a process that provides services to running
applications.
And the bytecode involved in that was about
four and a half megabytes.
Now, profiling this over 25 minutes as if
we were a method at a time JIT, found that
roughly 8% of that four and a half megabytes
of code was actually worth compiling.
The rest of it either wasn't executed or wasn't
executed enough to bother to try to speed
it up.
But then looking at it just in terms of hot
traces, it goes all the way down to 2%, so
2% for us of that large process mattered enough
that it needed to be optimized.
And this is kind of the benefit of a trace
compiler.
If we look at just the high-order bit of the
decision point, it was that the method JIT
could provide the best optimization possibilities,
but the trace JIT really does provide the
best return on investment, the best return
for the memory and processor spent in order
to do the translation.
So that's what we decided to go with.
The Dalvik JIT in Froyo is a trace-based JIT.
And, again, the key factors for us making
this decision was to minimize the memory use
and then also to get that performance coming
back to the user as quickly as possible.
One thing we worried about is, if we had gone
with another model, is the usage case of a
user downloading an application from the market
and then discarding it before it had been
running long enough to trigger the hot code
detection and the recompilation to give you
the performance that you needed.
With a trace JIT, the performance comes to
you just almost immediately.
Now, we also realized, too, that although
we kind of obsess over battery-powered Android
devices, a lot of times they're not really
battery powered and they don't really need
to be that responsive.
And that's when they're plugged in and charging.
When one of these phones is charging, it actually
looks a lot like a server, an environment
in which a method-based JIT is most appropriate.
While we're not doing it now, we're leaving
the path open that in the future, we could
perhaps bring in the best of both worlds,
have the trace JIT available to give the immediate
speed boost for a running application when
you're running battery powered.
And then when you're charging, when the phone
is not being used, perhaps a more advanced
method-based JIT could come along and do some
extra optimization.
But that's just a possible path forward.
Okay, so time for a flowchart.
Let's just walk through very quickly kind
of a simplified version of how the trace JIT
works.
So when I mentioned a trace is a string of
instructions, kind of a straight-line string
of instructions.
And that has to have a start.
We call the potential start of any trace to
be the trace head.
That's, you know, the point in the code that
the trace can begin from.
Let's say we're in the interpreter and let's
say we're at one of these trace head points.
Now, that's generally the target of a backward
branch, the entry point to a method, the target
of an indirect branch.
There are several possibilities.
The interpreter will say, hey, I'm at a potential
trace head, and so it will increment a profile
counter associated with that potential head.
Then it will ask itself, have I been here
enough that this thing matters?
In the beginning, the answer will be no.
So the interpreter will go back to interpreting
as fast as it can, until it comes to the next
potential trace head.
It will update its profile counter, ask the
question again, have I reached my threshold?
Is this something that's interesting?
And eventually, the answer will come back,
yes, this is interesting.
I've been here enough.
This is something I want to take a look at.
The next question is asked, do I already have
a translation for this address?
And if I do, then will this send execution
directly to that translation so it can start
translating natively?
But, again, let's say we're in the beginning
of the world.
The answer would be no.
So we don't have a translation for that address.
So we want to build one.
So we go into -- we go back to the interpreter.
So we're going to continue interpreting, but
we're going to continue interpreting in a
special mode.
We call this trace-building mode.
We essentially single-step the interpreter,
and every time we successfully interpret an
instruction, we'll add that instruction to
the list of instructions for that trace that
we want to have translated.
Now, how long we keep doing that and when
we stop, that's one of the tuning parameters
we have in the JIT.
Basically, you know, how many branches do
you follow before your trace is terminated?
At some point, we'll decide, okay, this is
long enough.
We want to terminate this trace.
And then we'll send the request off to the
compiler thread.
Meanwhile, the interpreter goes back to interpreting
so you can continue making forward progress.
Now, at some point, the compiler thread will
get around to compiling that trace into a
sequence of native instructions, and it will
install it into the translation cache.
Now, one of the -- something to keep in mind,
when we first put a translation in the translation
cache, it's going to have some -- all traces
are going to have branches that exit the trace.
When we first put it in the translation cache,
those branches that exit the trace are going
to be hard-wired to send us back to the interpreter.
So if the very first time we jump in, we do
the translation, then we get back to the interpreter
and go look for new hot traces to compile.
But on the way out, once we have completed
that trace and we're going back to the interpreter,
the question will be asked, is there a translation
for where I'm going?
And if the answer is yes, then we'll replace
that exit branch with a direct trace-to-trace
branch.
The upshot of this is that, in practice, very
quickly, we spend very little time in the
interpreter.
We'll collect all of our hot traces, chain
them all together, and so we're really just
bouncing from trace to trace to trace to trace
in the translation cache, with an occasional
bounce out to the interpreter to find some
other hot trace before we come back in to
the translation cache.
It works remarkably well.
Okay.
So that's kind of what I've already said.
Now, what I described was really the flow
for almost any trace-based JIT.
It's the basic flow model.
Some specifics about the Dalvik JIT.
We have a per -- a translation cache per process.
So every Dalvik process is going to have its
own private translation cache.
But all the threads within that process will
share that cache.
We have some simple traces right now.
This is kind of release 1.0.
So we're being conservative.
Our traces are not very long.
They'll generally be just one or two basic
blocks.
And a basic block in compiler terms is a string
of instructions followed by a branch out.
Our optimizations are pretty straightforward.
For local optimizations, we do register promotion,
load store elimination, if we can eliminate
null checks, we do so, and then we do some
instruction scheduling just on -- based on
some heuristics.
We've also got some nice loop detection code
in there.
So if we can detect a loop, we can do some
more -- more -- some of the simple loop optimizations
in variant code motion, and play around a
bit with the induction variables.
Okay.
So now this is really the slide that everybody
cares about.
How well did it work?
It worked out really pretty well.
This top chart here, it's -- the scale on
the left shows you how many times faster the
JIT'd code is than the interpreted code, the
JIT'd code in Froyo is than the interpreted
code that you would see in the Eclair release.
And we're seeing anywhere from two to five
times performance boost -- excuse me -- on
these kind of applications.
Now, again, this is -- just want to be clear
-- this is a performance boost of the interpreted
code.
So if you have an application that's already
spending most of its time in a native code
library, the JIT is not going to do much for
you because you're not really doing any interpretation
to start with.
This is an improvement relative to the amount
of interpretation that happens in the program.
But we're still pretty happy with it.
Now, the bottom chart, though, I'll have to
say, is actually the one that I'm personally
happiest with.
And this is an indication of how much memory
we consume in order to get this performance
boost.
If you look at that first one, LINpack, that
scale on the left is actually in kilobytes.
So we're not measuring memory usage in megabytes
or gigabytes, but actually, we're only consuming
100 or so kilobytes of total heap.
And this is heap for the profiling system,
for the JIT compiler itself, and the memory
used by the translations that are produced
by it.
And this is really a very, very small number
relative to traditional JITs.
So we're extremely happy about, again, the
return on investment, the performance we've
been able to achieve with the very small amount
of memory that we're using.
So what's next?
This is our first release.
We've got some nice plans going forward.
The two key optimizations that we didn't include
in Froyo that we're working on currently are
method in-lining and trace extension.
And by trace extension, I mean we're going
to have those traces run more than a couple
basic blocks, mostly so that we can identify
loops.
It's important to identify loops in the hot
traces so that you can perform the loop optimizations.
Other things we're looking at is persistent
profile information, off-line trace coalescing.
These are really things that address that
case in which we want to do something when
your phone is charging, when you're not actively
using it, to make things go faster.
And then, finally, tuning, tuning, and more
tuning will continue to make this thing better.
Okay.
So now I'm going to turn it over to Ben.
And he's going to tell you a little bit more
about the things you can do if you go out
and get the sources of the JIT and build some
of these special profile versions.
>>Ben Cheng: Okay.
Thank you, Bill.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Ben Cheng.
I'm also a software engineer in the Dalvik
team.
Now that you know the overall structure and
the performance figures in the version 1.0
and the Dalvik JIT implementation, in the
second half of the talk, I'm going to go over
the key techniques we used to address the
performance and the correctness issues we
encountered during the course of development.
If you're also a compiler hacker and plan
to make contributions to the Dalvik JIT project
in the future or even plan to port a JIT to
a brand-new platform, I'm sure you'll find
the following information very useful.
If you are an app developer, please try to
stay awake for the next five slides.
[ Laughter ]
>>Ben Cheng: And after those, you can just
sit back, relax, and enjoy the speedup from
the JIT.
So after the JIT infrastructure is in place,
the typical tuning, tuning, and more tuning
cycle starts with workload analysis.
Because if the majority of cycles are spent
in a VM interpreter, then that's a good benchmark
for additional JIT tuning, because the maximum
cycles that can be shaved by the JIT will
only be a fraction of those originally spent
in a VM interpreter.
So the tool we can use is called the OProfile.
And with the profiling information, you get
the rough idea on whether to expect a 5X or
.5% speedup from the JIT.
Once the workload is in -- the suitable workload
is identified, the next task is to verify
whether the JIT is able to migrate all the
cycles from the VM interpreter to the JIT'd
code cache.
Again, the profiler will be able to provide
you some insight to validate if that's the
case or not. What OProfile cannot provide,
at least for now, on Android platform, is
the capability to distinguish individual translation
boundaries in a code cache.
Therefore, it also lacks the capability to
map a translation to a Java source level.
So we wrote our own ad hoc profiler which
will instrument every translation with count
increment instructions.
And from the profile counts, you can find
out the hottest translations very easily.
And those are good starting points to find
out additional performance tuning opportunities.
In the third part of my talk, I'm going to
share with you some practical ways to debug
the JIT, like all our compiler projects, if
the compiler is crashing, a conventional way
to triage that is to selectively disable more
and more operations in the compiler until
the smoking gun is found.
Not only is that a tedious and a lengthy process
to begin with, the dynamic nature of the JIT
adds additional challenge to the triage process,
because the batch translation you are trying
to identify may not be compiled every time.
So we take a step further by converting the
frequent synchronization with the interpreter
to our advantage by designing a verification
framework that actively validates every single
line of JIT'd code against an interpreter,
which is considered the golden reference of
the VM implementation.
If there is any divergence detected there,
we will report that in a log and that will
greatly shorten the triage process.
Now let's move on to local analysis and benchmarking.
I remember in my school days, benchmarking
for a compiler is really boring.
I would run a single command to start a test
harness for spec 95 or 2000, and a few hours
later, I got a bunch of numbers come back.
If I'm using a simulator, I actually can plan
a day trip between two benchmarking runs.
In our Android device, since the most likely
CPU-intensive workload are games, I definitely
won't mind spending an extended period of
time playing one of my favorite games, RoboDefense
to measure its performance.
Well, it turns out that the CPU cycles spent
on the VM is really, really light in these
workloads.
So here is the OProfile result taken from
playing a game from level 00 to 080.
You can see that 74% of the CPU cycles are
spent in the skia library, busy drawing the
robots on the screen.
The time spent in the VM is actually only
4.34%, including the GC time.
So it turns out that this is a perfect benchmark
for skia tuning or even GCC tuning, because
skia is native code.
But the maximum performance gain you can get
from optimizing a VM is capped at 4.34%.
Now let's look at a different game, called
Checkers, from the Brain and Puzzle section
on the Android Market.
And this is actually written by a fellow Googler,
Aart Bik.
Now, regardless of the JIT, this is a perfect
benchmark, because that will clearly print
the number of nodes traversed in a fixed amount
of time on the bottom right screen.
And I may zoom in there.
So in the two screen shots here, the left-hand
one is the Eclair version or the interpreter-only
version.
The right-hand one is the JIT version, or
Froyo version.
And the play time is set to ten seconds.
As Bill mentioned earlier, we measured a 5.4X
speedup on Nexus One.
Because the score jumped for 965K to 5.2 million.
One fun fact about the game is that if you
look at the feedback on the Android Market,
you will find a few one- or two-star ratings,
because people think this game is too difficult
for users to beat.
So I'm pretty sure that the checkers players
will be among the first wave of Froyo users
to notice additional performance difference,
probably through frustration.
[ Laughter ]
>>Ben Cheng: And in case you were wondering
why it shows a remote cousin of the 099 go
benchmark from spec 95 to showcase the JIT
running on the 2010 Android device, well,
there are two primary reasons.
The first one is, the checkers is an easy,
accessible application on the Android Market.
And that can be used to measure the VM baseline
performance across different platforms very
easily.
The second reason is, tuning a JIT is like
tuning a muscle car, where you want all the
horsepower to stay in the power train instead
of being wasted by air conditioner or stereo.
So here is the ten-second profile result taken
from the JIT version, where the Dalvik JIT
code cache line accounts for all the cycles
spent in the code cache.
And libdvm.so accounts for all the cycles
spent in the statically compiled code.
The combined sum here accounts for 96.45%
of the overall CPU time.
And that's why optimizing the VM will provide
you the biggest bang for the buck for this
kind of workload.
On the other hand, if the game is modified
in the future to perform a fixed amount of
workload in the shortest amount of time, then
you can spend 80% of the CPU cycles doing
something else or simply sleep.
Now let's take a look at the breakdown between
the dynamic and the static cycles.
As shown here, the ratio is 97 to 3.
It means that the trace-based JIT did an excellent
job identifying all the hot traces in the
workload and migrated cycles from the VM interpreter
to the JIT code cache line.
Now let's move on to a second topic, which
is how to measure the effectiveness of the
JIT itself.
So in addition to the top-line performance
numbers, the amount of resource consumed by
the JIT is another important area we want
to monitor.
So if you load -- for example, if you want
to know the code bloat ratio from Dalvik bytecode
to the generated native code, because the
code cache is a fixed-size memory buffer,
and the lower the code bloat ratio is, the
more translations can be placed in there.
Right now, we don't have garbage collection
on the code cache, so whenever that gets full,
we just nuke it and restart from scratch.
And that's why we also want to know how fast
the JIT compiler can crank out translations.
So if you load the profiling version of the
VM onto the phone, at any time, you can just
send a user two signal or 12 to the pid of
the selected process, and a bunch of useful
statistics will be printed in a log.
For example, the numbers here are taken from
the system server process after using a phone
for 20 minutes, including checking e-mails,
browsing the Web, and making phone calls.
In this particular snapshot here, there are
9898 or close to 10,000 compilations made
during this 20-minute span, and they occupy
796 kilobytes in the code cache.
So, on average, each compilation takes about
80 bytes.
And although we are not doing method-based
compilation, we still try to keep track of
the total size of hot methods.
The way we do that is, whenever a trace is
picked up by the compiler thread, we also
identify the containing method and tag the
method as hot.
In this way, we can get a total size of the
hot choices and hot methods in the Dalvik
bytecode level.
So in this example here, the red number 104K
accounts for the total size of at least 10,000
hot traces.
And the green number, 396K, is the total size
of the hot method.
And as Bill mentioned earlier, the trace-based
JIT effectively only touched 26% of the Dalvik
bytecode in hot method.
Now that we know the total size of generated
code and original Dalvik bytecode size in
the traces, we can calculate the code bloat
ration, which is 7.7 in this case.
It is actually not as high as that appears
to be, because Dalvik bytecode is known for
its compact representation, and all the new
and arranged checks that couldn't be optimized
away are generated in-line by the compiler.
But there is always room for improvement,
and we'll definitely look into that.
And all the new and arranged checks that couldn't
be optimized away are generated in-line by
the compiler. But there is always room for
improvement, and we will definitely look into
that.
Now let's take a look at how fast the JIT
compiler can produce compilations.
The way we measure that is whenever a work
order is consumed by the compiler thread,
we take a time stamp. Then when a generated
code is installed in the code cache, we take
another time stamp. Then a delta here is the
work clock turnaround time per compilation
unit.
So an example here, to generate this 10,000
compilations takes slightly over six seconds
out of the 20-minute span. And on average,
each compilation takes about 609 microseconds.
Also note that the time measure here involves
the boot process which is very busy because
there are many, many threads containing for
the single CPU unit system.
So the JIT latency here can be considered
as the upper bound.
When a system is in a stable state, the JIT
latency we measured is typically in the 100
to 150 second micro second range.
Now, let's talk about the last performance
tuning in the talk, which is how to use the
JIT profiler to inspect the quality of generated
code.
Again, if you load the profiling version of
the VM onto the phone and enable a special
property, like that specified in the title,
you have effectively enabled the JIT profiler.
And at any time if you send a user two signal
to the PID of a selected process, all the
sorted profile counts will be printed in a
log. And the numbers here are also taken from
the system server process. I am going to use
the top row to go over the meaning of individual
cells.
The first number of 15368 is the total number
of times that hot translation is dispatched
and that accounts for 1.15% of the total dispatches.
The zero plus-2 283 top (inaudible) means
the beginning of the translation is also at
the beginning of the containing method. And
there are two Dalvik instructions, including
the trace. And it comes from line number 283
in hashmap.Java.
The verbose output of the top ten translations
including the Dalvik bytecode and the generated
thumb or thumb 2 instructions are also printed
in a log, and that will facilitate in-depth
code quality analysis. And I am going to show
you a verbose output momentarily.
Now let's move on to the third topic, which
is about the debugging and verification tools
we developed and how we strive to ensure the
highest level of stability of the JIT.
So right now let me turn on the phone. This
one.
And I will put that aside first.
So if the VM is brought on by a JIT bug, usually
it manifests itself either as native crash
in the code cache or on code exceptions in
the Java source level.
So the phone here I just turned on actually
contains an injected bug in one of the codegen
routines, and you will never make it to the
home screen. But if you look at the bug reports
in the log, you will see a variety of reasons
reported. Photograph for example, you will
see a run-time exception thrown in a system
server thread. And another symptom due to
the same injected bug is array index out of
bounds exception in the windows manager threat.
And yet another symptom due to the same big
is a stack overflow error in the system server
thread.
In case you are wondering what the injected
bug was, I basically made a one-line change
in the load constant routine so that all the
16-bit sine extended constant loaded by the
JIT will be one greater than the original
value specified in the byte code.
And this phone will be stuck in the miserable
state forever.
If you look at the crash reports, it is not
clear whether the injected bug -- whether
the bug is in the application itself or the
JIT compiler. And uncertainty like that will
definitely hinder the triage process.
So in real life, when we get an incoming bug
report concerning the JIT, the first thing
we do is to disable the JIT and try to reproduce
the problem in an interpreter-only mode. If
the problem just goes away, then we know,
okay, must be our fault.
And roughly speaking, the top two sources
for issues in the JIT come from code generation
routines and optimization routines.
In the early days, when a JIT does only type
of oh-zero type of code generation, since
there are 256 byte code in the system, there
are only 256 potential places for a bug to
hide. So the first debugging support we implemented
is to selectively disable an arbitrary set
of op codes for the JIT, and we used the interpreter
to execute those.
So as long as we can find a reliable way to
reproduce the crash, it's only a matter of
several rungs of binary search to root cause
the problem. And clearly, the injected codegen
bug can be found that way.
But as the compiler becomes more ask more
sophisticated and additional optimizations
like registry allocation or scheduling are
in place, the binary search mechanism becomes
less reliable because disabling certain op
codes might get rid of instruction mix that
triggers the problem.
So we also implemented a method based filtering
mechanism where as long as you can narrow
down the bug to a small set of methods, you
can enable or disable the JIT only for traces
coming from those methods to see if that makes
any difference.
As you may already have noticed here, the
triaging techniques we used here involves
constant toggling between the JIT and an interpreter.
And we are very motivated not to do that by
ourselves manually.
So the ingenious idea we came up was to hire
a summer intern last year.
[ Laughter ]
>>Ben Cheng: And the name of the project is
self-verification.
Instead of locking the intern in his office
doing verification all by himself, we actually
worked together by designing a brand-new verification
framework based on tricks to roll back and
commit the memory states.
So basically, the VM is able to execute the
same instruction sequence twice by two different
execution engines in an interleaved way.
At the end of both rounds we do a state comparison
and report the divergence detected there.
So we call that self-verification.
And because the execution and the verification
all happen on the same physical device, without
user intervention, and it is capable of detecting
both code generation and optimization bugs.
So now let me turn on the second phone here
which is loaded with the same code generation
bug, but with self-verification enabled. My
prediction is it will be able to tell you
exactly where the injected bug is, and fixing
that will take less than three minutes. But
before that happens, let me quickly go over
the work flow of self-verification.
So if you take a snapshot of the VM state,
there are three categories of information
that matter. The content on the stack, the
content on the heap, and the Dalvik PC. So
the verification cycle starts by creating
a shadow copy of the top frame on the stack.
And we only need to care about the top frame
because currently, the trace is confined in
a single method boundary.
All the heap accesses in the trace are intercepted
and emulated at run time. So all the store
to the heap will be stored in the simple table
data structure by the address and data pair.
And all the loads from the heap will be routed
to the table first to see if there's any recent
update from the same trace. If not, the content
will be served by the real heap.
Then we dispatched a JIT'd code, and that
it execute to the end. Then we will remember
the end PC.
Then we restore the PC to the beginning value
and it re-executes the same instruction sequence
using the interpreter.
We will know exactly when to do state comparison,
because right now there is a maximum number
of instructions that can be including a trace.
So if we hit the limit before seeing the end
PC, we know we have a control flow divergence
and we will just report that.
Otherwise, when the end PC is met, we just
initiate a state comparison and report any
divergence detected there.
So, in fact, we can configure the self-verification
in one of two modes. Blocking versus nonblocking.
If we just implement a brand-new optimization,
we want to run that in the blocking mode because
the VM will just freeze the application if
there is a divergence detected, and that will
get our immediate attention.
But if the goal is to find corner case
bugs which may take longer to surface, we want
to run that in the nonblocking mode where
the VM will allow the application to continue
as long as the debug information is recorded
in the log.
In this way, you can do stress testing on
your primary phone, 24 by 7, without the worry
that the phone is not functional when you
need to use that.
And so the phone here, the second phone here
is actually running a self-verification in
a nonblocking mode. And that's why the phone
is still usable.
And I am going to use the extracted example
here to go through the meaning of the debug
information, and I am going to show you the
life log after that.
So first you will see a clear message telling
you that some kind of divergence are detected
in the registers.
It will also tell you the class name, method
name and the Dalvik PC of the offending translation.
Then it will tell you the instruction sequence
executed by the interpreter before the divergence
is detected. In this case here, the interpreter
executes a constant 16 instruction followed
by if greater equal instruction.
It will also tell you where the divergence
comes from. In this case here, it's in the
v0 register in the Dalvik stack frame. In
the interpreter versions it's B5. In the JIT'd
code it's v6. And remember the injected bug
is count 16 where the JIT'd value is one greater
than the interpreter value.
Since we manage the code cache by not only
storing the generated code but also the original
trace information, we can easily replay the
compilation request with verbose mode turned
on so that you can see the Dalvik code and
the corresponding native code.
And that's exactly the same mechanism used
by the profiler to report the content of the
hot translations.
So in this particular example here, um see
that the constant 16 is trying to load value
181 into V zero and since we know the divergence
is in V zero we just follow the native code
that touches the same location on the stack.
Right now the registry allocator will reserve
R5 as the frame-based pointer. And since V0
is the first slot on the stack, so we know
it must the store R0 R5 plus zero that deposits
the bad value onto the stack.
Then we follow the used stack chain on R0.
Then we see, oh, this move here is trying
to load 182 to R0, but the original byte code
is trying to load 181, and bingo, we have
found the bug.
Now let me show you the life log spewed on
the phone here.
I just type AVB log Cad. You can see a lot
of live debugging information is spewed on
the phone as we are using that.
And hopefully through the example here, you
see there's trends of self-verification, because
that's easy to use. It provides really good
test coverage, and you will isolate and report
any problem found.
And that's why we get to spend more time writing
useful optimization code than debugging.
Okay. So to wrap up today's talk, over the
past year, our team has delivered a resource
friendly JIT for the Dalvik version machine
from ground up. We pay special attention to
the memory overhead, so that it can fit the
budget on embedded systems. And through a
set of CPU intensive workloads, we demonstrated
that it can provide 2 to 5x speedup over the
Eclair release. And we already have new optimizations
waiting in the pipeline, and we believe JIT
will enable a new class of applications for
the Android platform. So in your new application,
if you can provide an easy way to find out
the performance numbers, like the checkers
game, we'll be more than happy to use your
application as a real world benchmark to explore
new optimization opportunities in the JIT.
And last but not least, we have the hard working
verification robot in the Dalvik land, so
that's why we encourage people to just sit
back, relax enjoy the speedup from the JIT.
Thank you. That's all we have.
[ Applause ]
>>Bill Buzbee: Now we have some time to take
a few questions.
And probably best to go to the microphone
so that people can hear.
>>Ben Cheng: There's one.
>>Bill Buzbee: Yes.
>>> Okay. I'm just curious, before you --
since you are verifying the JIT against your
interpreter, are you 100% sure you don't have
bugs in the interpreter?
>>Bill Buzbee: Yeah, the -- we're -- the interpreter
has been pounded on quite well.
In fact, one of the reasons why the interpreter
is such a nice thing to compare against is
that it's really -- you can think of it is
that there's only 230 or so Dalvik bytecodes.
And the interpreter deals with them individually.
So you can individually validate each of those
230.
What makes the JIT more difficult to validate
is that when we optimize, we're interleaving
instructions, we're rearranging things, and
so the combination effects makes it much tougher
to validate.
The interpreter is relatively simple to make
sure that's correct.
And our interpreter's been solid for quite
a while.
>>> Okay.
Second quick question.
When you have a trace that contains a branch
instruction, or when you start -- you mentioned
stitching traces together, how do you know
that the state of all the variables, the stack,
the heap, anything that trace can refer to,
is consistent between multiple runs of that
trace?
In other words, how do you know the trace
-- the trace is actually valid if it includes
a branch instruction when you start running
it, how do you know you're actually going
to start following the branch when you run
the trace ahead of the branch instruction?
>>Bill Buzbee: So the trace will kind of re-evaluate
all of its variables as it's running.
The one -- what you may be getting at is
-- Ben, do you want to talk a little bit about
the predicted invokes?
>>Ben Cheng: Yes.
So for Java virtual calls, we try to chain
the call side to the most likely callee.
But we do keep a live profiling count as the
invocation is dispatched.
If we find that we mispredict too often, we
will try to rechain that to the currently
most likely callee.
So we do have some dynamic learning system
in the JIT'd code.
>>>
So if I understood correctly, for each process,
you compile; right? So it's separate.
So how about system libraries?
Do they also compile each time in each process?
>>Bill Buzbee: Yes.
So in this release, the answer is yes.
We don't pay attention to where the execution
comes from.
And so if multiple processes are using the
same system code, each will have its private
hot traces.
And those traces may be different from process
to process.
We have explored some future possibilities
of having some kind of canned, precompiled,
preoptimized traces for common system stuff.
But we don't have that in first release.
>>> And I have a question, it's not directly
related to JIT, but how about garbage collection,
can you say anything?
Did it get faster on Froyo?
>>Ben Cheng: All we can say is we have colleagues
currently working on that.
>>> Okay.
>>Ben Cheng: But maybe that will be the next
milestone release.
>>> Okay.
Thanks.
>>> Hi.
I had two questions.
The first one was, does it work on X86?
And the seconds was, are you generating Thumb
instructions and ARM instructions or just
Thumb or what's going on?
>>Bill Buzbee: Okay.
So this release -- this release of the JIT
is for ARM processors.
And we will generate -- in general, we try
to generate Thumb instructions for the traces,
but we'll occasionally branch out to common
routines that are done in ARM.
And we'll either generate Thumb or Thumb-2,
depending on the -- what's supported by the
underlying processor.
We also will understand whether the underlying
processor has VFP floating point, and we'll
either use those instructions or generate
calls out to run-time support routines to
handle floating point.
It's configurable when you build the JIT.
>>> And so only -- only ARM right now?
Is that what you meant?
>>Bill Buzbee: That's correct.
Only ARM processors today.
>>> Okay.
>>Ben Cheng: do you want to ask a question
from the moderator?
>>Bill Buzbee: Oh, moderator questions.
Power savings.
So the power savings question is much like
the general performance.
We -- a little bit like that.
When we're doing less -- you know, taking
less CPU cycles to do the same amount of work,
we'll be saving the power that would have
been consumed by those CPU cycles.
I wouldn't expect you to notice a big power
difference in normal usage, because the primary
consumer of power on the devices is generally
going to be the display and the radios.
And then what's left over is the CPU and memory.
And we'll compress the CPU cycles somewhat.
So we expect that to be positive, but it was
not the primary motivation for doing the JIT.
Performance was the primary motivation.
>>Ben Cheng: So the next one is how well does
the JIT compiler use the native processor?
Does it produce generic ARMv 5 code or is
it smart enough to optimize on ARMv 9 with
neon extensions.
>>Bill Buzbee: I think we answered that one.
It's configurable.
>>Ben Cheng: The next is, what kind of memory
footprint is the JIT compiler aiming for and
how much will be left for the application
after enabling JIT compilation?
So we aimed for 100K.
>>Bill Buzbee: Our target was about 100K.
The Nexus One has more memory, so we kind
of relaxed the constraints for that.
But it's also a configurable thing, too.
We can kind of cap the max usage of memory.
But, in general, we were shooting for about
100K bytes per process.
>>Ben Cheng: Yeah, so I think we'll answer
the last question here.
So people's tests indicate it will be up to
450% faster, but how noticeable is the change
to the end user?
So the answer is, your mileage may vary.
So suppose you have a workload where 50% of
the cycles are in the graphics and 50% in
the VM.
Even though we provide 5X speedup on the VM
part, you're only going to notice 40% gain.
So it really depends on the distribution of
the work cycles to begin with.
And I think we have run out of time.
>>Bill Buzbee: Oh, yes.
>>> One more.
>>> (inaudible) has had Gazelle instruction
set for quite some time, and Android for now
is primarily targeted for ARM, you know, hardware.
Do you -- can you elaborate on Dalvik's use
of Gazelle instruction set?
And if not, is Google working with ARM for
future optimizations on the chipset itself?
>>Bill Buzbee: Well, let me just make that
really brief.
The -- we're not using the -- actually, I
think what you're shooting for is the Thumb-2e
extensions that kind of are in ARM processors
to support JIT compilation.
Those are good things, but if you look at
them more carefully, what they really do is,
they will boost an interpreter's speed when
it's handling bytecodes one at a time.
Okay?
They make things go faster if you don't try
to intermix instructions.
The gain from the JIT happens because we're
able to take a collection of instructions
and interleave them with scheduling and optimization.
And in that environment, the kind of hardware
execution of bytecode model actually holds
you back a little bit.
So we believe we're faster with this model
than we would have been if we had actually
used hardware acceleration of individual bytecode
execution.
And I think we are -- we are really out of
time.
>>Ben Cheng: Okay.
Thank you.